encuentra el área del semicírculo pausa
en el vídeo y traten de ver si pueden
resolver esto por su cuenta sabemos que
el área de un círculo es igual a pi por
radio al cuadrado si pensamos en el
círculo completo cuál será su área nos
dicen cuál es su radio es 2 así que el
área del círculo completo es igual a pi
por 2 al cuadrado 2 al cuadrado es 2 por
2 que es 4 así que el área es igual a 4
pi pero no podemos poner 4 pi aquí ya
que nos están preguntando el área del
semicírculo y este 4 pi es el área de
todo el círculo completo y el
semicírculo es la mitad del círculo por
lo que el área del semicírculo va a ser
igual a la mitad de esto así que aquí
escribimos 2 pie en lugar de cuatro
unidades cuadradas
tenemos otro problema ahora el lugar del
área
nos piden la longitud de arco del
círculo parcial que es lo que tenemos
aquí en color azul
tenemos que encontrar esta longitud de
arco y vemos que esto es tres cuartas
partes de la circunferencia del círculo
aquí es igual la circunferencia sabemos
que es igual a dos pi por radio nos
dicen cuánto vale el radio es igual a
cuatro por lo que no está circunferencia
va a ser igual a dos por pi por cuatro
esto es dos por pi por cuatro por lo que
va a ser igual a 8 pi
esta es la circunferencia del círculo
completo pero si queremos conocer esta
longitud de arco va a ser tres cuartas
partes de la circunferencia del círculo
completo por lo que va a ser igual a
tres cuartos por 8p tres por ocho es 24
entre 4 va a ser igual a 6 por lo que
esto es igual a 6 pi
otra forma de verlo es una cuarta parte
de 8 es 2 y 2 por 13 6
y otra forma de verlo es una cuarta
parte de chopin es igual a dos pi por lo
que tres de estos va a ser igual a seis
pi así que la longitud de arco de esta
circunferencia parcial va a ser igual a
seis pi encontramos esto porque nos
dimos cuenta de que esta longitud de
arco es tres cuartas partes de la
circunferencia total de este círculo
como supimos que eran tres cuartas
partes pues porque aquí tenemos un
ángulo recto que mide 90 grados y que es
una cuarta parte de una circunferencia
completa por lo que la longitud de arco
que nos interesa es tres cuartas partes
de nuestra circunferencia